we
really for many many years have divided
our understanding of what makes us all
different
into genetics and environment the fur
the clip i showed you was one around
nature our individual differences have
to do with our genes
there's a genetic blueprint it's our dna
and it carries out what it's meant to do
and then the other side of it which
clyde
always went on about he said environment
trumps genetics he loved that word
trump's
is that it's all environmental and so
we're born as a blank slate
and the environment writes on it and we
now know that neither of those points of
views are correct
and also it's not correct to add the two
together
to take let's say 40 percent of our
individual differences in a trait are
from the genes
and 60 are from the environment and when
you add them together you get this
that's also not correct instead there's
an interplay between the genes and the
environment
and clyde spoke about this beautifully
in the video the beautiful video that
cfar put together
so what do we mean by interplay well one
thing we mean
is that our genes are actually listening
to the environment and the experience
that we have
are changing as bruce said the way our
genes are expressing or functioning
so let's just go back now why would
clyde have
really been disturbed by this video
because for many years
as an epidemiologist he and his
colleagues had realized
that there was a biological embedding of
experience the term that he coined
and as bruce said whoops sorry
there's two devices for me to control
here makes it too challenging
anyways as bruce said if you have early
experiences of abuse
neglect this gives you a much higher
chance even if this happens
only early in life to have health risks
and so on average kids are put on a
developmental
path or a developmental trajectory and
it's
towards health wellness social
functioning well-being
and it is influencing influenced by what
happens to them early on
it's also important what happens later
but those early years are very critical
we want to know how to prevent these
early experiences
often associated with low socioeconomic
status
and they reflect the gradient and health
that clyde talked about so often
and what's particularly interesting to
me is that there are individual
differences
in this response so some individuals as
i'm going to say
would be highly affected by this and
others not
but overall there are differences when
you've had this
adverse early experience in neural and
endocrine responses to stress as bruce
told us
in brain development as we heard from
bruce and
also its function and the immune system
and even the gut microbiome
the the organisms that are in our gut
and we had a very interesting cfar
meeting about that in the last two days
now tom boyce and bruce ellis put
forward this idea
that our children when born um could be
more like
dandelions if there is stress that they
experience
they'll do okay just like a dandelion
they can grow in the cracks of the
sidewalks
whereas the orchid child needs to be
watered
and grown in the right humidity and then
they'll flourish
i i asked tom how can i figure out if my
kids are orchid or dandelion children he
said just put
really woolly socks on them and the
orchid kid runs around screaming it's
too itchy
i think i have two orchid kids but
so what does what do these ideas mean
this is something
around gene by environment interactions
so
if you know about the genetics what
genotype someone has
for any given gene you might look at the
serotonin
transporter for instance but there's
many many of them
we have two forms one from our mother
one from our father and in a population
we could end up getting two that are the
same
or two that are different and so that's
something we can read in our dna
and if we only know that it doesn't tell
us what the response of that individual
is going to be
across the potential environments that
an individual could experience
whereas if we know about the environment
they grew up let's say
with a lot of adversity in early life
compared to very little adversity
that alone does not tell us how these
individuals with two genotypes are going
to act
so let's take for example this is the
early
adverse environment all the way to a
very positive environment and let's say
we're measuring maternal sensitivity
how sensitive the mum is to the baby
this is something we've done as part of
the maven project with allison fleming
and michael meaney and others in the
room
and we find that if we look at two
genotypes we find that one is like the
dandelion
it is it does not respond to an early
environment
of adversity at all it's always
behaving in the same way in terms of the
sensitivity
as it gives that child as a parent
however the other genotype is more like
an orchid it's highly affected
when it has very adverse experience when
that mom is
grows up with abuse or neglect and then
when there's positive experience
there's a high sensitivity level for
that mom
so we need to know both about the gene
the genetic architecture and the
environment and there's an
interplay we can't know this whole story
without knowing both and this is what we
mean by interaction
and these kind of graphs are really
common whether we look at my fruit flies
and whether they have early nutritional
adversity whether they're going to be
exploratory or not
whether they excrete a lot of poo i mean
i could show you all kinds of exciting
data about my flies today but
sadly i only have 10 minutes so this is
what gene by environment interaction is
now the other thing is epigenetics these
are two mechanisms whereby
our experience can get embedded in our
biology
and what you can think of in terms of
epigenetics is that dna is like
books packed in boxes and stacked in a
library
and that epigenetics changed the
likelihood that these
these dna will be read that the dna will
be read
and examples of factors that induce
epigenetic changes
are listed here social interactions
they're all here
nutrition smoking and so
that dna how it's read how much it's
going to be expressed or not
will depend on your experience so this
is what i mean by the
genes are listening to the environment
and just in a very um
pictorial way we see that when
the uh early environment is adverse
this dna that wraps around other
proteins
in the chromatin it's almost like it's
covered up and it can't be read or
expressed
and in these more positive environments
the dna is easier to read
and in epigenetics it's not turning on
or off this gene expression it's more
like a dimmer switch that
up or down regulates the capacity for
that gene to express
itself and the work of many people in
the room and others has shown that early
adversity changes the likelihood
that some genes will be read just like
bruce said about the glucocorticoid
receptor gene
involved in stress and that how we cope
with stress how our brain develops and
works
and how we fight disease okay so one
quick example from michael meaney and
moishe ziff
we have a rant mom and that mommy licks
her pups
a lot or a little and so this is how it
would work if this is epigenetic
we have the mom who licks a little bit
and the one who
licks a lot and these are her pups who
get licked a little bit or a lot
but you can cross foster them and then
ask the question what happens with these
guys
when they have a biological mum that
licks a lot but their experience is to
be licked a little bit
do they end up being mothers that have
to do with
their biological background or their
experience or some combination of both
and what they've shown is that it's the
foster mum that matters
for so for this glucocorticoid receptor
you can look at
how much of the gene is expressed what
matters is a foster mum so here we have
the biological mum
first the foster mom second and you see
that when the foster mom is a high
liquor and groomer
that baby grows up to be a high liquor
and groomer of her pups
and so it's and then the opposite is
true for the foster mom that's a low
liquor and groomer
so somehow this parenting has been um
inherited in in this means what's the
consequence of this
the mom's behavior social context
affects the lifelong health of the
infants via later stress reactivity
the mom's behaviors transfer to the pups
in an epigenetic manner
it's as though epigenetics is a
mechanism for nurture
changes to the epigenome are really a
cellular memory of an
environmental event now epigenetics is
in its infancy and there's still many
things that we don't know
is it reversible is it transgenerational
we have some beautiful work from a new
person in our
child and brain development program
elizabeth binder showing that the
epigenetic machinery can interact with
the dna sequence variation to affect
post-traumatic stress disorder and then
what are the consequences of all this
for brain plasticity and lifelong health
so in our child and brain development
program at cfar these are the kind of
questions that we are
tackling we know that early experience
sets developmental trajectories for
health behavior across a lifetime
how does this happen we talked today
about
gene environment interactions we bring
with us predispositions to behave a
certain way
but our environment writes on our dna
and changes it
through the through changing expression
when
when do these positive environment
impact
inputs matter or when are the adverse
ones
causing problems so this whole idea of
critical or sensitive periods in
development
windows of opportunity where the brain
needs that stimulation in order to
develop in an optimal way
we're very interested in studying that
what early experiences matter is a huge
issue if one compares a slow drip of
neglect
how is that different than one or two
instances of abuse
we don't really know the answers to
questions like that
and then where should we be only looking
at the brain we know now that the brain
and the body are having conversations
and so
we want to ask questions about that and
finally all of this work
comes together to answer the question
which hopefully many of us will talk
about today
how can we make a difference and help
every child reach their potential
okay great
you